the most important thing to know about
visual effects is that no matter how
revolutionary or sophisticated the
technology we use is it still takes the
beating hearts and minds of human beings
to make movie magic as filmmakers and as
as actors in the 21st century we can
create any world we want we we can we
can play anything we want
kriste if you were to put on a motion
capture suit right now you could play
anything from a planet threatening
megalomaniacal monster to to donald
trump and actually it's not very diverse
but anyway having had the honor of
working with many of the greatest I have
a real special appreciation for from the
master craftsmen and women who dedicate
themselves and find the delicate balance
between illusion and flesh-and-blood
here are the nominees for this year's
achievements in visual effects Star Wars
The Force awakens Roger guy Patrick Tula
Neal Scanlan and Chris Korell
next popular and Whitehurst Paul Norris
Mark Addington and Sara Bennett the
round Richard Pryor
Matthew Shumway Jason Smith and Cameron
wall bar the Martian Richard stammers
and if Langlands Chris Lloyd's and
Steven Warner Mad Max fury road Andrew
Jackson Tom would Dan Oliver and Andy
Williams and the Oscar goes to ex
machina and writer Mark Antony and
cerebellar
for a nomination for Andrew Whitehurst
Paul Norris mark arting to an end
that
Oh
I'm really bad at predicting this
apparently this is so utterly unexpected
visual effects is massively a team game
more so maybe than than any other
department and we have to thank people
in two directions we've got a thing we
called a famous studio we've got to
thank the production we've got to thank
Alex for being an amazing director we
have to thank Alicia for being a ver and
we have to thank the the teams of
artists production and technical
personnel at double- milk VFX and utopia
who are amazing
without them we are nothing thank you so
so much